getting three spider-man together
couldn't go one of two ways spider-man
no way home ushered in 20 years of
legendary spider-man and gave fans the
moments we all wanted you think we were
emotional tell that to our amazing
spider-man andrew garfield who has
recently revealed his quite
extraordinary experience during the
process we're swinging into some of the
amazing moments and experiences that
garfield had during his journey in no
way home
number one andrew garfield spider-man
had a rough time at the end of his
second movie dealing with the failure of
losing his love gwen stacy like
acceptance of loss acceptance of death
van speculated ever since the no way
home trailer that he'd be the one to
save mj and boy were they spot on as the
battle ensues between the spiderman and
their universe's villains mj takes the
tumble off the statue of liberty holland
speeder tries to save her but fails
which gives garfield's peter an
opportunity to rectify his greatest
failure it actually feels
like a great creative idea andrew went
on to explain how this moment in the
film really healed his character and
felt it helped his character move on
from the guilt he was feeling for so
long as he held mj in his arms
remembering gwen
number two the uniting that we all
waited and guessed for finally came true
and what a scene that was seeing our
spidey heroes fight together it was a
big double kind of capitalized yes but
we weren't the only ones feeling the
hype and emotion garfield could barely
contain himself on set when they shot
this he recounts his experience as one
of the best scenes he's ever gotten to
do and how great it felt fighting
alongside toby maguire and tom holland
and him being the ultra spider-man fan
that he is he knew fans were absolutely
going to love this moment how profoundly
moving that is unto itself
number three we all know that andrew has
a big heart for his co-stars in no way
home and that final moment between the
three spider-man moved him so deeply oh
no this is gonna people are gonna like
this movie a lot
after the parkers defeated and spared
the invading villains holland must say
goodbye to his mentors the moving moment
was created by a genuine encounter
between them off camera as holland came
in for the hug garfield was compelled to
say i love you guys which brought us all
to tears this surprised everyone on set
as it was not scripted and improvised in
this touching moment we can feel the
love from this trio and we appreciate
him a lot more
number four when he was brought on to
reprise his role andrew felt he was
given the opportunity for his spider-man
to mentor tom hollins have us have our
presence being in service to tom and we
saw how tom talked to his older spider
bros getting the knowledge he needed to
save the villains andrew became a big
force in the way holland's character
changed and even helped change maguire's
too being basically the middle child of
the spider-man franchises made him feel
like that middle child that mentors and
seeks guidance at the same time i found
that deeply moving mentorship and the
theme of mentorship let's also
acknowledge the fact that the middle
child of the family is also the funniest
and we can all agree that he had some of
the funniest moments in the film
number five andrew's iconic amazing
spider-man suit was brought back and no
way home and andrew was definitely
relieved to say the least they created
zippers and flat and two zippers for me
not only was he thrilled to don his
original suit yet again but he didn't
have to suffer like the rest of the
spider-man actors while most of the
on-screen spider-man had to suffer
through the nose zipper suits garfield
was the only one that got lucky we've
all heard the horror stories of using
the bathroom when you're spider-man and
let's just say the others weren't too
happy for him toby and tom were a little
jealous of their new friend and thought
they'd been bugged out of the costume
relief design aspect all joking around
of course and we're hoping holland will
finally get his wish of having them for
his suit sooner or later
number six andrew was dealing with
back-to-back films before no way home
released so of course he's got all the
questions about his involvement in the
film it's super easy to dodge reporters
but dodging an x and spider-man co-star
not so much emma kept on texting me and
she was like are you in this new
spider-man film as press gossip ensued
emma stone decided to get an inside
scoop from her former lover with a
flurry of texts interrogating him of his
involvement in the film he held his
ground even to gwen stacy herself he
just couldn't reveal it she wasn't too
happy about it either but we're sure
there's still a platonic love between
the two and a longing to work together
again
number seven it didn't take much
negotiating to get andrew on board but
he did in fact have one deciding factor
to putting the suit back on and that
reason was for toby i was just waiting
to see if toby was gonna do it we
wouldn't think of anyone who wouldn't
want to act alongside their childhood
hero and garfield being the spider geek
that he is he just couldn't do it
without him he's always had a very high
respect for tom too but he wouldn't miss
out on actually fighting alongside
cinema's first spider-man i followed
toby to the to the end to the end of the
earth number eight on top of the toby
reason for coming back garfield was also
very captivated by the emotional depth
of the story it's just it's the it's
classic peter parker he revealed that
when he was approached by marvel
executives to join the film he was told
the purpose and basic outline of the
script and he was so moved by its
dedication and emotional tones he gave
them a big yes andrew always showed
praise for spider-man and its actors and
felt this was a great reason to bring
him back into holland's journey also
feeling that tom's movies embodied an
independent film vibe which we all know
andrew has always excelled in as an
oscar-nominated actor
number nine after andrew had to abruptly
pass on the spidey gauntlet tom holland
felt pretty bad for snatching it from
him of course it was neither hollins nor
garfield's decision but tom still felt
he should have at least called him to
tom's surprise there were never any hard
feelings when he finally met andrew he
was so gracious to tom during their
encounter and even gave him some super
special spidey advice
number 10 we never want to see our
favorite actors leave their title roles
and sometimes they don't either that's a
huge concern for garfield as he's saying
that he doesn't want his time together
with the other spider-man to end i would
love to continue working with toby and
with tom i think that kind of three
brother dynamic is so i don't know juicy
but his desire to keep coming back could
certainly open up a lot of possibilities
with not only another group film but a
highly desired third film from his
original franchise we're hoping the
power of fans and andrew are enough to
persuade filmmakers to bring him back
and why wouldn't we after the success of
the multiverse story there's no telling
what his next villain could be or quite
possibly an alternate universe is gwen
stacy coming back into the mix to fight
alongside him you know never say never
number 11 andrew's pants were on fire
for months before the release of the
third spider-man film and he expertly
weaved the best lies to keep fans up in
the air i definitely think i have that
honest time you had the worst part of it
marvel secrecy has always been very
important and with something as big as
the spoilers for this film garfield was
forced to stay quiet he flat out lied to
every interviewer who asked him a
question about his return and he was
pretty crafty about it i call it fibbing
more than lying even when he was
confronted with the damning leaked piece
of evidence on the tonight show starring
jimmy fallon he still kept his cool just
enough to keep fans still hoping but not
to give anything away i did see it
and it's a photoshop it wasn't all
marvel compelling him to keep quiet
though he felt that keeping the secret
would make the moment of his reveal even
bigger to fans when it finally came time
number 12 being together on the big
screen for the first time brought every
spider-man fan to the edge of their
seats andrew tom and toby all felt the
love on set together and it showed in
every interview after the film's release
me and toby snuck into a theater
together no one knew we were there they
got along so well during the process
that hanging out off-set was the new
norm and with andrew and toby being so
close they decided to go on a little
movie date together sneaking into a
showing of their big film and
experiencing all the emotional moments
with fans we have no words to describe
seeing three of our beloved spider-man
actors unite and we cannot wait for what
is to come of andrew garfield's amazing
character do you think andrew's journey
has yet to end or do you think his
character should stay where it's at
let us know in the comments